[Musique]
la guerre est déconcertante elle mêle
danger et fort physique incertitude et
hasard
en faisant le choix du métier des armes
le soldat fait le vœu de défendre la
France et ses intérêts nationaux allant
jusqu'au sacrifice ultime mais on ne
n’est pas guerrier on le devient
marchons dans les pas de combattants
pour qui se forger une force physique
mais surtout morale a été le fruit d'un
entraînement acharné
bonjour à toutes et à tous nous allons
donc vous présenter la mission et je
laisse la parole OJ2 les deux États ont
réussi à en quittant le cocon familial
Paulo s'est lancé un défi devenir pilote
de chasse dans l'Armée de l'Air et de
l'Espace comme il ne suffit pas
d'enfiler un treillis pour être un
aviateur entraîné il a suivi trois mois
de formation militaire à l'école des
officiers de Salon-de-Provence
alors l'objectif de la formation
militaire général de l'officier c'est en
réalité trois choses la première c'est
de la culturer les jeunes recrues et qui
viennent du monde civil au monde
militaire la deuxième chose c'est de
faire réfléchir ces jeunes à
l'engagement qui est le leur de devenir
officier au service de la nation avec
tout ce que ça implique derrière c'est à
dire la probabilité de donner la mort
c'est quand même pas anodin et puis la
réflexion sur le sens du service et de
l'engagement et puis la dernière chose
est non des moindres c'est de donner
tous les outils nécessaires à ces jeunes
pour rapidement ils puissent exercer des
responsabilités de commandement
[Musique]
et là les gars vous prenez en main votre
raid à partir de maintenant vous
commencez et c'est parti c'est bon c'est
ici que tout se joue pendant 4 jours les
élèves vont puiser dans leur ressources
intérieures pour accomplir la mission
qu'il aura été confiée malgré des
conditions difficiles infiltration
collecte de renseignements immersion en
zone hostile
pendant l'horaire de synthèse on va leur
demander de restituer l'intégralité de
leur formation notamment au niveau de la
guérissement du combat de la topographie
des franchissements et les amener à une
restitution sur des phases dynamiques et
statiques cette falaise de 100 mètres
soit l'équivalent d'un immeuble de 30
étages est un obstacle vertigineux mais
ce qui est attendu d'un militaire c'est
qu'il fasse preuve de courage pour
continuer à avancer malgré la peur
pour les plonger dans un état de fatigue
comparable à ce qu'ils vivront en
opération extérieure les élèves vont
marcher pendant des heures ils n'auront
que 20 minutes de répit pour dormir
cette nuit là
ils vont dormir dehors notamment avec
des bivouacs donc pas entente et ils
sont amenés aussi à se dépasser sur le
plan mental mais aussi physique et
travailler en groupe puisque on leur
demande un esprit de cohésion et de
corps chose qui n'ont pas forcément en
arrivant du civil et qui doivent
acquérir à la fin de ces trois mois pour
ensuite arriver dans leur futur unités
on arrive au niveau de la chapelle du
Pâtis et là tout le monde se place donc
nous
on est là depuis 5h30 du matin environ
après une grosse phase d'infiltration à
pied toute la nuit et là du coup depuis
ce matin on met en observation et
renseignements on essaie de voir tous
les mouvements qu'il y a qui passent par
là qu'est-ce qui se dit vu qu'on est
assez proche des parents de guépard 5
on a donc 13 PACS confirmés avec des
armes qui sont en train d'essayer
du premier pas le roam me donne plus de
pack sur zone Confirmer le nombre de Pax
sur zone
[Applaudissements]
au niveau de la face nord ils sont
attrapé unités
l'échange d'armes terminé les ennemis
quittent la zone les élèves officiers
sexfiltre en toute discrétion on est sur
la phase d'essuration de la mission donc
on a réussi la phase d'observation on
vient de regarder tous les objectifs
pendant 8 heures à peu près et donc là
c'est la marche pour monter le
mouvementée ça va être assez costaud je
pense on a 1000 mètres de dénivelé
positif donc ça va grimper assez fort
nous on est un peu fatigué mais c'est le
dernier effort et on va y arriver je
pense
finalement le fait de savoir marcher
toute une nuit dans des conditions
difficiles nous permettent de nous
sentir capable de et se sentir capable
ça permet en situation réelle de réagir
sainement
dans notre métier qu'on soit
l'entraînement ou en opération on prend
des risques considérables
dès lors qu'on met le pied sur une
échelle sur l'échelle de la viande de
combat qu'on pilote ou dans lequel on
vole on en a conscience
polo sera peut-être un jour à bord d'un
avion de combat survolant les zones de
conflits mais se confronter à la
rusticité du terrain est indispensable
dans sa formation militaire
que j'y gagne c'est me rendre compte que
voilà l'armée de l'air est aussi dans
toutes les armées c'est pas que les
avions c'est des gens qui sont au sol si
jamais j'arrive à être dans un avion il
faut comprendre comment ça se passe en
bas pour mieux gérer si finalement la
situation si on n'arrive pas à se mettre
à la place du personnel qu'on va aider
ça va être difficile et aussi en tant
que pilote de combat on peut même plus
tard être exposé à une éjection par
exemple se retrouver un terrain style et
à ce moment-là marcher plusieurs
kilomètres ne pas se faire opérer par
l'ennemi arriver à survivre avec peu de
vivre et c'est là que je trouve que le
Red synthèse il prend tout son sens
ce matin s'achève votre formation au
sein de la section de l'instruction
militaire qui a fait de vous aujourd'hui
des combattants avant de devenir des
chefs donc félicitations à tous vous
avez tous fini la formation dans
l'intégralité de la promotion donc bonne
continuation dans vos unités
lorsqu'un jeune choisi de servir son
pays sous l'uniforme il sait qu'une
transformation latente au premier rang
pour constater cette métamorphose la
famille
je ne sais pas et lui il le fait et
quand il me le raconte c'est toujours de
l'enthousiasme c'est toujours j'ai pris
du plaisir j'ai fait j'ai fait ça j'ai
fait la descente en rappel j'ai monté le
Mont Ventoux on a dormi dans le froid et
on voit cette photo où il y a tout le
groupe et qui sont dans la neige et
effectivement l'air fatigué je me dis
c'est une belle victoire quoi c'est
Polo a encore du chemin avant de voler
dans un avion de chasse plusieurs années
de formation au métier de pilote
l'attente désormais dans ces conditions
de vol polo est loin de se douter que
l'atmosphère terrestre est un
environnement inospitalier pour l'homme
car le corps humain n'est pas adapté à
la troisième dimension
le département de médecine aéronautique
opérationnelle de la base aérienne de
Mont-de-Marsan sensibilise les
personnels navigants des trois armées au
phénomène physiologique qu'il
rencontreront en vol
un élève pilote de la Marine nationale
va être mis en situation de
désorientation spatiale
comme vous voulez n'hésitez pas à
commenter
c'est plus facile pour votre cerveau
c'est une cabine opaque donc le pilote
qui est installé dedans va être mise en
condition de vol sans visibilité il
n'aura plus du tout de perception
visuelle et on va générer des illusions
sensorielles qu'il pourrait ressentir
sur certaines phases de vol par des
mouvements de la cabine que l'on peut
faire dans les trois plans de l'espace
donc engage en roulis en lacet
on va amener le pilote à prendre
conscience que les illusions sont
Sorelles sont un phénomène totalement
normal qui va toucher toute personne et
que son instrumentation de bord est là
pour supplémenter ses limitations liées
à son propre corps son oreille interne
c'est une expérience qui est très
révélatrice qui est assez marquante
parce qu'on se rend compte qu'on peut
pas vraiment se fier nous-même et à nos
sensations ça désoriente ça nous
déséquilibre c'est c'est le mot donc
c'est très instructif
merci le jour où en opérationnel il va
ressentir une sensation qui est erronée
par rapport à ce que va lui apporter son
instrumentation de vol il aura bien
conscience que si l'écoute ses propres
sensations il va se mettre en danger en
danger qui peut aller jusqu'au crash et
jusqu'à sa mort la désorientation
spatiale est un vrai danger elle est la
cause de près de 20% des accidents
aériens avec collision au sol mais en
entrant dans ce caisson Raphaël va
expérimenter un autre risque lié cette
fois à l'altitude donc le caisson
hypo-bar fonctionne par des variations
de pression ce qui fait qu'on va
reproduire la pression la faible
pression que nous avons en altitude pour
monter finalement fictivement nos
stagiaires au niveau de 25000 pieds
niveau auquel ils font l'hypoxie dans le
cadre de leur formation ce sont des
symptômes finalement sont extrêmement
variés et qui varient beaucoup d'un
individu à l'autre
champ des petits picotements
en fonction des gens ça peut être la
tête des fourmis dans les mains ou dans
les pieds on peut avoir des problèmes au
niveau de la respiration il respire
souvent plus fort le pot qui s'accélère
et après on peut avoir des problèmes au
niveau complétif c'est à dire que il
réfléchissent plus lentement voire ils
prennent des mauvaises décisions
sinon niveau cognitif pas de
ralentissement
trop facile les calculs
ça nous fait 400
relevez bien la tête on se laisse
glisser tout doucement dans cette sorte
de maladie de l'altitude et on perd vite
pieds on passe au dessus de plein de
détails et en fait on se rend compte que
ça s'installe de manière insidieuse et
ça peut avoir des conséquences assez
dramatiques comme on a pu le voir le
raisonnement complètement perdu très
difficile de se concentrer et pourtant
nous dans notre perception des choses on
est plutôt à l'aise le temps passe d'une
manière rapide agréable et quand on
prend un peu de recul par rapport à tout
ça c'est là qu'on se rend compte de
l'envergure de dégâts alors je vous
demandais si ça allait parce que je vous
voyais les yeux qui fermaient au fur et
à mesure comme si vous étiez en train de
vous endormir c'est un effet de
l'hypoxie aussi gentiment vous allez
vous éteindre d'où l'importance d'aller
rechercher le moindre petit indice qui
très très tôt vous mettra la puce à
l'oreille et très très tôt vous
permettra de prendre une décision ça va
triste
pour les personnels navigants connaître
ces phénomènes physiologiques et
primordial pour la sécurité des vols car
aller à l'encontre de ses sens et faire
confiance à la machine peut être une
question de survie
à terre les soldats se battent également
contre les éléments il subissent de
plein fouet les conditions extrêmes du
pays dans lequel ils sont déployés à
Djibouti la chaleur écrase l'humidité
étouffe le vent fouette les visages
c'est particulièrement important de
s'entraîner dans différents milieux
parce que chaque milieu impose des
contraintes physiques et morales
différentes le jour où on se retrouve au
combat dans ce milieu en se raccroche à
ceux qu'on connaît et donc on a déjà un
certain vécu parce que il y a déjà
milieu qu'on maîtrise et donc finalement
il y a plus que les paramètres de combat
gérer avec près de 4600 militaires
déployés au Sahel barkhane et la plus
grosse opération extérieure française
l'environnement abrasif de Djibouti et
donc le terrain d'entraînement idéal
pour les soldats amenés à opérer dans
ces zones arides chaque année ce sont
près de 1500 militaires qui sont formés
ici au centre d'entraînement au combat
et d'aguerissement au désert pendant 5
jours les hommes du premier régiment par
parachutiste vont apprendre à dompter ce
milieu par tous les moyens tu fais déjà
des températures 40 degrés et c'est prêt
on fait ça sur du sable donc forcément
c'est pas le plus agréable mais c'est ce
qui nous fait ce qui rend la chose un
peu plus rustique donc si on arrive à se
battre dans ces conditions là
on arrivera ailleurs donc c'est pas plus
mal
après deux heures de corps à corps
adrien est à bout de souffle pourtant il
va devoir rapidement reprendre ses
esprits car un parcours d'obstacles
l'attend le groupe va devoir travailler
main dans la main pour franchir ensemble
les différents ateliers dans une
obscurité totale démontrer qu'on est une
équipe on est soudés vous pouvez compter
sur vos chefs vous pouvez compter sur
vos camarades vous pouvez compter sur
vos subordonnés ensemble on est plus
fort on est prêt
[Musique]
l'atelier tu es presque tout se passer
sauf qu'à la fin il y a un des mecs il a
il a lâché l'échelle du coup on a dû
tous recommencer
ça ça met un peu la rage mais c'est pas
grave on a recommencé et puis surtout
les autres ateliers à tous les chéris
donc c'était ça l'essentiel quoi c'est
juste garder l'esprit groupe
pour aller au combat ensemble il faut
avoir une confiance aveugle en son frère
d'armes et c'est à travers ses activités
collectives que le groupe se soude les
ans aquatiques n’est justement pas le
fort de tous les stagiaires ils vont
donc devoir se serrer les coudes
on se sous-estime souvent et c'est aussi
ça qu'apporte la guérissement c'est
qu'on a l'impression qu'on ne va pas y
arriver que la marche est trop
importante et finalement petit à petit
cette marche on la monte et même on la
dépasse et donc à la fin c'est une
réelle satisfaction de se dire mais je
suis bien plus capable que je ne
l'imagine et cet effet de groupe en plus
m'amène encore plus loin la mythique
voit de l'inconscient elle étape la plus
redoutée du stage il leur faudra faire
preuve de courage et d'endurance pour
venir à bout de ses 10 obstacles à flanc
de falaise
partout quand on dit un stage commando
on parle du Gucci on parle de la loi de
l'inconscient on parle de l'asperge de
la gouttière qui sont assez hautes assez
imposantes donc forcément on arrive
dessus on se dit faut pas se louper quoi
et forcément on se met une petite
pression parce qu'il y a faut le faire
moins de 25 minutes mais il y a pas
insurmontable comme tout il faut juste
se donner les moyens et avoir envie de
gagner quoi et puis ça passe tout seul
la difficulté de ce parcours c'est comme
toutes les épisodes c'est un mélange de
cardio et de bras principalement
donc tous ceux qui
n'ont pas une bonne condition physique
avant de venir le centre tout de suite
il y a pas de beaucoup de phase de
course mais c'est très aérien donc ceux
qui ont peur du vide
personnellement le côté symbolique
c'était par rapport à mon père parce
qu'il était génère ici donc il avait
fait plusieurs fois donc marche sur ces
traces ça me fait ça me fait plaisir
forcément je voulais vraiment faire un
bon chrono je vais rattraper deux
personnes devant moi au moment d'arriver
à la gouttière j'ai ça glissait trop
j'ai pas après j'ai pas cherché plus que
ça j'ai pas voulu perdre trop de temps
j'ai pris le chemin de contournement et
j'ai fini comme ça j'arrive à faire 15
minutes donc ça va
ça va faire mieux mais ça va
je pense que c'est toujours intéressant
pour l'encadrement d'un stage de
guérissement ou d'un stage commando de
jouer sur la dimension psychologique et
le fait de déjà dire que ça va être
quelque chose d'insurmontable que seuls
les meilleures y arriveront qu'il va
falloir aller le chercher qui va falloir
se dépasser et bien prépare chacun dans
sa tête à aller se dépasser à aller
chercher le l'impossible et finalement
il y a déjà un conditionnement avant
même d'avoir été confronté à la piste
d'audace après avoir accompli
l'impossible les corps sont meurtri
malgré la douleur d'une tendinite ce
soldat n'envisage pas d'abandonner et
ira au bout du stage
les prochains jours sont dédiés à
l'entraînement au combat en milieu
désertique le terrain va rendre la
progression du peloton difficile ils
vont devoir faire preuve de pugnacité
pour avaler les 30 prochains kilomètres
dans une zone et demie cette fois c'est
un exercice mais déployer au Sahel il
pourrait être confronté à ce même
scénario
la préparation est vraiment bien axée
sur tous les outils qui seront utiles au
mont on passera au combat évidemment
tant qu'on n'a pas combattu on peut pas
connaître nos réactions en revanche on
essaie de limiter au maximum l'écart
entre notre réaction à l'entraînement et
notre réaction au combat
[Applaudissements]
le programme c'était de nous faire
travailler les bases du combat il y a
des articles dans des conditions de
haute intensité qui vont nous permettre
on va dire qu'on acquiert les
automatismes qu'on a acquis ici qu'on
est plus les restituer sur le terrain
je dirais qu'il y a un lien entre
guérissement et la confrontation à la
mort dans la guérissement il y a guerre
les morts font partie de la guerre quand
on sait guérit le but c'est on dit que
la sueur épargne le sang c'est de
préparer le corps et l'esprit à se
dépasser pour éviter au maximum la mort
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]
mise en place de la pluie et donc on a
fini mutuelle au sein des Plessis
au régiment en France ou ici à
l'étranger et donc forcément il y a des
bas en fait on vit les uns sur les
autres et l'esprit de groupe il n'est
dans l'adversité quand on fait une piste
groupe quand on fait du combat quand
c'est dur quand il fait chaud et de
cette rusticité de cette difficulté va
naître une cohésion entre nous quoi donc
c'est
c'est ce qui va nous permettre après sur
le terrain de savoir quoi faire parce
qu'on se connaît entre nous en fait on
devient des frères en fait donc c'est
donc c'est très beau quoi
dans l'armée de terre on parle de frères
d'armes mais dans la Marine nationale ce
qui prime c'est l'esprit d'équipage car
pour plonger pendant plusieurs semaines
à bord d'un sous-marin coupé du reste du
monde il faut un sens du collectif bien
particulier
avant d'être marin on a un esprit
d'équipage très très développé beaucoup
plus que sur notre unité de la marine on
sait le que chacun un poste important
peu importe peu importe sa fonction même
moi attends chef du quart j'estime que
le petit matelot qui pilote il a autant
de responsabilités que moi c'est lui qui
a une joystick dans les mains c'est lui
qui le connaissait réactions d'urgence
et si on n'était pas entraîné et si on
ne sait pas régir aux avaries voilà on
peut mettre en jeu la situation marin et
perdre le sous-marin et donc perdre tout
l'équipage
entre chaque plongée les équipages
s'entraînent à terre pendant 6 à 7
semaines à l'école de navigation
sous-marine de Toulon les simulateurs
fidèles reproduction des équipements du
sous-marin permettent un entraînement
immersif sur la plateforme sécurité
plongée Michael et le chef du poste de
pilotage
donc ici on entraîne les équipes à
toutes sortes de la variétés à bord tu
es en train de surface de centrale
surface surface surface c'est la raison
pour laquelle nous sous-mariniers sont
formés à des réactions d'urgence selon
les avaries et la survie d'un équipage
peut reposer que sur une seule personne
et la guérissement c'est s'assurer que
les sous-marinés même en dehors de leurs
zones de confort dans une situation de
stress intense soit en mesure de pouvoir
réagir
le sous-marin est un bâtiment de guerre
qui mène des opérations pour la plupart
méconnues du grand public pourtant au
fond des abysses là où règne une douce
illusion de quiétude les équipages ne
sont pas protégés du chaos en remontant
jusqu’à la Seconde Guerre mondiale les
forces sous-marines comptent plus de 200
victimes le sous-marinier il a
conscience de ça que à un moment donné
il sera vulnérable sur les sous-marins
nucléaires d'attaque quel que soit nos
missions que ce soit des missions de
collecte de renseignements de mise en
oeuvre de forces spéciales d'Escorts
d'unités précieuses on est une bonne
partie du temps emporter des armes
adverses et c'est là où nous chez nous
la mort c'est une mort dont on a
conscience parce qu'on sait pertinemment
qu'elle est pas individuelle elle est
collective et collective c'est plus de
70 marins 2 3 7 on est d'accord sur
cette deuxième plateforme Mickaël
s'entraîne à la navigation et à la
conduite d'opérations les nombreuses
heures passées sur ces simulateurs ne
servent pas seulement à acquérir des
automatismes
l'atmosphère d'un embarquement y est
reproduite obscurité bruit et longuation
horaires situation de stress intense
avenue de 23 sur le premier c'est
contraintes on va retrouver l'isolement
l'isolement par rapport à l'extérieur
l'isolement par rapport aux familles il
est poussé en dehors de sa zone de
confort car c'est un métier qui
nécessite une grosse charge mentale une
forte concentration donc il ne faut pas
que les soucis du quotidien à terre
deviennent les soucis du marin à la mer
une alerte sur la frégate on a pris une
troisième émission sonore on aperçu un
changement dans l'échelle de balayage la
frégate a augmenté son échelle on était
en 0,45 elle est passée en 0,90000 elle
défile toujours bien gauche à gauche on
était en silhouette 15 gauche ok mode de
mission la vie à bord d'un sous-marin
c'est une vie non-stop où on peut
travailler parfois plus de 12 heures par
jour et il est important que chaque
sous-marinier connaisse ses limites et
c'est bien là le défi en dépit de la
fatigue on dépille de l'activité c'est
être en mesure individuellement et
collectivement de durée dans le temps
un éloignant dans le rail montant donc
supérieur à 12 mm c'est un métier de
passionné donc les contraintes on les
connaît mais on les accepte et en fait
je pense que souvent la passion prend le
pas sur les contraintes
bien sûr des fois on se dit les
contraintes sont dures
mais la mission en vaut la peine
[Musique]
c'est marin sont durement entraînés à
supporter l'isolement la promiscuité le
manque de sommeil c'est aguerrissement
psychologique est primordial car la vie
de l'équipage et la réussite de la
mission repose sur les épaules de chaque
sous-marinier embarquée la guerre est un
caméléon elle change de forme en
fonction des circonstances des acteurs
et de leur but le retour des conflits de
haute intensité en Europe impose à la
France de s'y préparer dans un
engagement majeur la force morale
individuelle et collective est un
facteur clé du succès c'est dans la
guérissement qu'elle se forge une
expérience singulière qui est vécu
différemment par chacun
pour moi la définition du terme
aguerrissement en fait ce serait un
processus qui vise à finalement nous
préparer à la guerre au mieux ça passe
par quoi ça passe par nous exposer à des
choses auxquelles on n'est pas habitué à
nous faire nous dépasser nous-mêmes dans
duré le combat dans durée l'abrasion du
terrain de d'accepter la perte d'un
camarade au combat ça vous donner des
outils aussi pour nous ouvrir vers les
autres puisque la guérissement n'est pas
individuel mais collectif et ça va
permettre d'avoir une symbiose au sein
de la de la brigade et finalement c'est
ce qui crée cet esprit guerrier ce qui
crée aussi cette émulation cette
cohésion et qui nous amène à aller
au-delà de l'individu mais plutôt sur le
commun et cet esprit guerrier on le
perçoit vraiment
[Musique]